i have no choice
well every time you find yourself here
it's because you chose to come back
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about the first two episodes of the new
show severance that just premiered on
apple tv plus i thought this was a
promising start the first two episodes
were titled good news about hell and
half luke and i find myself wanting to
know what's going on with the severance
program in the basement of blumen
industries i thought i'd take a closer
look at the episodes and the new series
which i'll do right after this quick
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
episodes 1 and 2 of severance season 1
yet then this video won't be for you and
with that out of the way let's get into
it the pilot episode opens with an
overhead shot of a character named
hallie waking up on top of a conference
table we'll eventually learn this is the
beginning of her orientation process and
one of the things that hooked me right
away was this decision to open from
helly's perspective since she's in the
same boat as we are as viewers i'm
sitting here wondering why would a
professional be laying on a table in
this setting where is she how did she
get there and these are all questions
that she doesn't have answers for what
she does have is a disembodied voice
coming through a conspicuously retro
looking intercom asking who she is she's
pretty freaked out and tries to leave
the room but eventually when she
realizes she can't do that she gives in
and agrees to answer the questions to
her surprise she can't answer any of the
questions that relate to her personally
the only one she does come up with an
answer for is when she's asked to name a
u.s state or territory in other words
she doesn't know who she is or what
state she was born in but she does know
what the states are we learn that the
voice belongs to mark who is conducting
this survey for the first time after
being promoted to the macro data
refinement department chief at the
company they all work for lumen
industries he's taking over the role for
his best friend petey who he learns is
no longer with the company they work on
the severed floor which means that they
agreed to have a surgical procedure that
separates their work consciousness from
the one they have when they're outside
the office heli explains this to herself
in a video saying she gave consent for
her perceptual chronologies to be
surgically split separating her memories
between her work life and her personal
life the memories are spatially dictated
they're unable to access outside
recollections in the office and can't
retain work memories after they leave
she acknowledges she understands the
process is comprehensive and
irreversible you see how this works when
mark comes into the office at the
beginning of the episode his audi the
person he is when he's not at work is
upset to the point of crying before he
enters the building as he takes the
elevator down to the severed floor you
see him change over to his any
personality there's this great sequence
where he's walking down this long
sterile hallway you see that he throws
away the tissue that audi mark was
wiping his tears with inside the car and
it's pretty clear that the innie has no
recollection of what was bothering him
to the show's credit it does a pretty
good job of making this all seem
workable the way that they introduce
things to get you thinking about them
and then coming back to show the same
situation from the other perspective
gives you the sense that they've really
thought things through it's a pretty
great premise that's also a little
tricky if you were so inclined you could
probably poke a lot of holes in it but i
thought they did a good job in how they
presented it of course we meet his
severed co-workers irv has been there
the longest and he can remember a time
when they incentivize their good work
with coffee creamer like a lot of the
details you pick up it's hard to say if
that's something that's important or not
dylan seems like a go-getter that has
this super entertaining cynical side and
he's out to win the holy grail of the
current incentives the waffle party
that's awarded to the top refiner of the
quarter
you also meet his bosses who appear to
not be severed miltek oversees their
work in the macro data refinement
department and as their boss he has
information about their inside and their
outside lives the fact that he leads
heli through the onboarding process he's
even there when she has her procedure
done and he's the first person she sees
when she tries to leave through the
stairwell that was enough for me to
suppose he's not severed but there are
also a couple of articles i've read with
the actor where he confirms that i
imagine this is the case for their boss
harmony coble as well i'm not saying
there isn't anything weird going on with
these two but would they really be able
to do their jobs if they had the same
process done to them ms koble is also
audi mark's neighbor mrs selvig and she
appears to employ two different
personalities in relating with him as a
strategy at work she's distant and
generally a tough boss and outside she's
warm and friendly this is emphasized in
her two stories about her mother at work
she describes her as an atheist who told
her that hell is just a product of a
morbid imagination but that whatever
humans can imagine they can usually
create at home she describes her as a
catholic who said it takes the saints
eight hours to bless a sleeping child
and she hopes mark isn't rushing them in
both cases she's trying to get him to be
a better employee and it'll be
interesting to see how engaging both
sides of him plays out what they
actually do during their work hours is a
big mystery you see it consists of
looking at screens full of numbers and
separating the scary looking ones into
different bins this is how they explain
it to heli anyway who doesn't get it at
all at first but she's able to see it by
the end of the second episode when he's
asked about working at lumen in the
outside world the woman asks if he
designs the medicines and then someone
interjects that they thought lumen was
more on the tech side of things on the
package for the microchip they implant
in their brains the company name reads
lumen medical technology it's also
mentioned that it's been around since
the 1800s started out making topical
solves and that's followed up with the
question what don't they make overall it
sounds like a conglomerate or a mega
corporation and it's not clear if their
logo that resembles a droplet is a major
clue towards their history or what the
severed workers do specifically mark
doesn't exactly take to his new role as
the head of the department even though
he tells heli who answered unknown for
four out of the five questions that she
got a perfect score she just isn't
taking to the orientation process she
even throws the speaker at his head
which gives him an injury and that earns
him a gift card at the end of the day it
does seem important that the note gives
a fictitious account of what happened
since it goes to show that they could
tell their audies anything about what
goes on at work and they wouldn't know
the difference to this point audi mark
is a little less interesting than what's
happening to his innie at work he lost
his wife in a car accident and we aren't
given all the details but this is
something he clearly hasn't gotten over
this is probably why he was willing to
shut his brain off for eight hours a day
through the severance procedure and at
home he drinks a lot which perhaps
that's him trying to shut it down there
as well he used to be a history
professor he has a sister who he's close
with even though he might not be a great
match for her husband and their
pretentious friends as witnessed at the
no dinner dinner party the most
intriguing thing that happens outside
the office is that petey interrupts his
vip dinner at pips to tell him that he's
been unsevered mark doesn't know who he
is but he does take the card he gives
him and that starts the ball rolling for
him wanting to know more about what
lumen's actually doing to them in the
second episode after he has a bad date
that includes a run-in with protesters
from the whole mine collective who are a
local group against the severance
process plus a visit from ms selvig who
brings over some cookies audi mark calls
out of work and does go looking for
petey the address on the back of his
card leads him to an abandoned
greenhouse where he finds his
ex-colleague who still isn't sure what
they do at work either being unsevered
hasn't made that any clearer but he is
sure that something creepy goes down in
the break room and he has a tape to
prove it earlier in the episode mark
took the blame for heli tripping the
code detector in the elevator and that
landed him in the break room of course
his audi has no recollection of that
happening petey is also trying to draw a
map of the severed floor and tells mark
that he left the original at work for
him to find after their conversation
mark decides to bring petey home and let
him stay in his extra room he is
suffering from reintegration sickness
which doesn't look fun and when he gets
a phone call that causes him to cough up
blood
in episode two we also get a look at
audi helly having her procedure done
what stands out about this whole
sequence is that she seems enthusiastic
about it and that it does appear to be
somewhat routine irving's been there for
three years so this is something they've
been doing even though we don't know how
many people have actually had it done
and it seems apparent that there's a lot
more than just the people that we've
seen so far considering there's talk of
legislation and that people are
protesting this idea you see that the
next thing helly's audi experiences
after going under is the stairwell
incident and you see that from the other
side it turns out milicek was there to
help turn her around because even though
her innie is fighting all the way her
audi does actually want to be there
because she's the audience surrogate in
the equation she has a ton of questions
about all the different aspects of their
jobs there are not a lot of straight
answers though there are a lot of
details that fall on a spectrum from
funny to possibly incredibly important
and that makes it hard to parse what you
should actually pay attention to her
work self does want to quit and no one
else in the office thinks that she'll
have much luck with that the last big
thing that happens is herb nods off at
his desk he pictures black sludge
pouring into his cubicle which is also
something that features heavily in the
great-looking title sequence that we
first saw at the beginning of this same
episode for his infraction he gets sent
to a wellness check where ms casey tells
him tidbits about his audi in an almost
hypnotic way he does get warned not to
react to any of the facts because he's
supposed to enjoy them all equally
without preference this does seem to be
soothing to irv's any even though it's
all fairly strange and i do think it's
interesting to note the different
non-severed people that they encounter
outside her office irv does meet another
severed worker named burt the head of
optics and design they share an
appreciation for a painting of the
company's founder kier egan swinging a
whip at a goat wearing a robe who has a
jester and a couple of women standing
behind him burt finds it calming and it
seems like these two have formed a
connection
so there are a lot of mysteries to
speculate about i really appreciated the
design of things the tech the long
hallways the artwork the handbook
illustrations and the flow of the
training materials it's all very sterile
but still manages to look stylish or at
least stylized the cast is amazing and
it's hard to pick out a favorite
performance because they all seem vital
i feel like each of the characters
delivered more than one memorable moment
already and we're just getting started
this is absolutely an abusive situation
where the victims have to ponder what
drove them to their decision daily while
also having this experience that doesn't
truly feel like it ever ends everyone
who works in the basement subjected
their innie to a helpless existence one
that they presume to be irreversible and
they did that willingly i wondered about
when this was supposed to take place and
found an interview with the creator dan
erickson where he said it's not a far
off future it's around now it's like
vaguely now as he said we're not going
for something where this is 10 years in
the future where severance has been
invented and already exists it's sort of
an alternate vaguely nourished timeline
so they had an intentional plan to keep
a lot of ambiguity to the time and place
and as far as the technology is
concerned they also intentionally never
fully decided how things worked even for
themselves
for me this adds to the uneasiness of
everything and i think it sounds like a
good choice to make it about the
characters and what they're experiencing
more than specific details that's part
of why i want to hold off to see where
things go before i get too attached to
any speculation about what's happening
i've read some different theories some
of those are pretty well thought out
about what the numbers mean and even
some where people think that what they
see is different than what we see but
i'm guessing we'll get more information
each week and at that pace it might be a
while before things come into focus it's
also possible for the reasons i
mentioned in relation to the choices
they've made that this will remain vague
even at the end of the season i am super
curious though because there are so many
little weird details in the first
episode there were these big glasses of
water on the tables at his sister's
place and at pips that kind of stood out
there's some real potential in the cult
of kier egan and all of his imagery
around the office the painting that erv
and bird enjoyed so much is completely
bizarre mark's crystal head cube that's
not a prize it's just something they
gave him and what was going on with
erv's dirty nails and is audi liking the
sound of radar it's also a nice bonus
that thanks to the setup the characters
have their own theories about what
they're doing and i think that's a good
place to leave things let me know in the
comments what you thought about these
episodes what you think about the
premise behind the show and what you
think is happening down in the severed
basement floor at lumen industries
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon